[Music]
pleasant surroundings
good food
food well prepared and served
no matter what type of restaurant
whether the coffee is made from a glass
pot or poured from the silver urn
a quick snack or a hamburger or dinner
in a plush night spot
a school cafeteria serving hundreds of
children
or your local coffee shop serving your
mid-morning coffee break
all these have one thing in common hands
this food
the health of your customers
is in the hands of the food handlers
in your hands
[Music]
i'm a registered sanitarian which means
i'm licensed by the state to carry out
educational and inspectional duties and
enforce the law in the field of
sanitation
as you accompany me on an inspection of
a few typical restaurants you may better
understand my job and how we can work
together to provide a higher standard of
sanitation
this place is an example of excellent
cleaning and maintenance it's old and
has been added to as the business group
and it doesn't have the advantages of a
modern layout and facilities but the men
who manage this kitchen know that every
detail must be looked after
all it takes is soap and water
a broom some rags a mop and men who will
do the job
clean dishes glasses and silver must be
stored in a clean place
shelves must be easy to clean glasses
and cups upside down
handles toward you so they can be picked
up without fingering the eating surfaces
many cases of food poisoning come from
dirty cutting boards the ideal place for
bacteria to grow
even a well-run kitchen such as this
might overlook a few small cracks in the
cutting board
an efficient hood for the stove will do
a great deal to keep the place clean
it is hard to keep a range clean
especially the corners
it is easier if you keep at it all the
time instead of waiting for a big load
to accumulate
the steam table is another place often
neglected but it requires just as much
attention constantly
keeping food clean is sometimes a matter
of protection
this compartmented refrigerator prevents
food from being contaminated by other
containers and foods
under a refrigerator is a good place to
watch out for rats mice or insects
the slicers grinders mixers must be
taken apart daily
if they're not you can be sure that
bacteria will find them an ideal
breeding ground
clean uniforms and a place to change and
store street clothes is a good idea and
an important part of cleanliness
good service is important
it perhaps more than anything else
brings the customer back
but good service is more than a pleasant
smile and friendly efficiency
there are some tricks of the trade and
it takes a lot of skill
a good waiter or waitress is as
concerned with the health of the public
as with catering to its twins
clean uniforms both behind and in front
of the counter is an obvious example of
this
so
nobody's likely to notice if you hold a
plate properly when it's served but they
certainly will if you don't and your
thumb gets in their food
most customers whether they put down a
dime for a cup of coffee or an
extravagant tip for a meal want to be
treated as guests in a fine home
but even an experienced waitress can
make a slip this one shows us how easy
it is to forget and let your fingers
touch the insides of used glasses and
plates
germs and bacteria can quickly be
transmitted this way the correct way to
clean a table protects you as well as
the customer
i've asked this bartender to do some
things he wouldn't normally do
he covers his cough but what about the
ice
everything that comes off his hand goes
under the drink and no matter how
generous the bartender nothing will stop
the customer from getting full benefit
of the extra dividend
wiping the customer's cigarette ashes
from the bar with his hand won't help
matters
just as an ice scoop protects the
customer from anything the bartender
gets on his hands proper glass washing
is another good protection
just polishing with a towel won't help
especially after he's coughed in his
hands and wipe them on the towel
if a customer is going to get sick let
it be from
natural causes
small restaurants have their own special
set of problems when there are only a
few people to do all the chores of
running a small restaurant it is hard to
observe good sanitation practices but it
must be done
all equipment including counters must be
cleaned regularly cream and sugar must
be kept safe from flies and dirt by
proper containers
when i inspect your restaurant i have a
checklist to see that good sanitation is
being practiced i check on such items as
these
dirty dishes that are contaminated by
customers either sneezing by their
breathing but the surfaces that touch
their lips
be careful not to touch these areas
this protects you the food handler
proper storage of cool foods in shallow
pans three inches deep is essential
keep cold foods cold
and hot foods hot
garbage attracts flies if the cans are
not well covered and the area is not
clean
lids must be tight and always in place
flies repel customers and spread disease
of course all the work spent keeping a
place clean will be wasted if the food
handlers don't keep themselves clean
washing your hands should be a frequent
item
pushing up the sleeves
using plenty of soap
scrubbing well on palms backs of hands
and fingers this is the correct way
careful rinsing and drying complete the
process
remember clean hands is a part of your
job
the health department inspects your
establishment to see if it meets the
minimum requirements of the law written
to protect the health of the public
preparing food in large quantities
requires just as much attention to good
sanitation
this school cafeteria is a good example
hair nets
keep your hair neat and also keep it out
of the food
there would be little food poisoning if
everyone observed the practice of
keeping hot foods hot and cold foods
cold
that turkey for tomorrow's sandwiches if
left on the table to cool would be an
ideal place for dangerous bacteria to
grow and multiply
put it in the refrigerator immediately
frequently check to see if your
refrigerator is running at the proper
temperature
remember to be safe
cold foods are foods under 40 degrees
keep hot foods
140 degrees or over
people like their hot foods hot and
their cold foods cold but bacteria like
everything lukewarm
thus if you satisfy your customers you
don't have to worry about bacteria for
in general bacteria like the same foods
that people like meats gravies dressings
cream pies and potato salad
even here in the serving line good
sanitation comes into play
plastic gloves are used to prevent
contamination
the principles of good dishwashing are
the same here as in any restaurant the
main point is care and constant
attention
an automatic machine like this can be a
big help but even it needs a check to
make sure the temperature is high enough
lukewarm water won't kill germs
their health
the health of your customers
is up to you
your hands handle the utensils your
hands arrange and prepare the food
your hands set the table
your hands take the orders and serve the
food
and they clean up when heating is
finished clean up ready for the next
customer
keeping your hands constantly clean is a
part of your job good sanitation is in
your hands
[Music]